how do you typically close those out
then I'm quite like organic with it all
just about how do you feel about it do
you think this could be a good
partnership the main object is if like I
need to have a think about it if someone
needs to think about something you've
not given them enough information either
I've not done a good enough job
explaining like what we do as a business
or maybe you do need to speak to someone
I just will be like excellent I'm going
to send you our you know terms and
conditions let me know if you've got any
questions let me know if there's
anything unhappy about that's when the
objectives come because they're like
okay how much do you charge